-Performing "My Love" from her
new album "Dance Fever,"
give it up for
Florence + The Machine!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I was always able to write
my way out ♪
♪ Song always made sense to me ♪
♪ Now I find that
when I look down ♪
♪ Every page is empty ♪
♪ There is nothing to describe ♪
♪ Except the moon still bright ♪
♪ Against the worrying sky ♪
♪ I pray the trees will get
their leaves soon ♪
♪♪
♪ So tell me where
to put my love ♪
♪ Do I wait for time to do what
it does? ♪
♪ I don't know where
to put my looooooove ♪
♪ And when it came,
it was stranger ♪
♪ Than I had ever imagined ♪
♪ No cracking open of heaven ♪
♪ But quiet and still ♪
-♪ All my friends
are getting ill ♪
-♪ So tell me where
to put my love ♪
♪ Do I wait for time to do what
it does? ♪
♪ I don't know where
to put my looooooove ♪
♪ So tell me where
to put my love ♪
♪ Do I wait for time to do what
it does? ♪
♪ I don't know where
to put my looooooove ♪
♪ My arms emptied ♪
♪ The skies emptied ♪
♪ The billboards emptied ♪
♪ My arms emptied ♪
♪ The skies emptied ♪
♪ The buildings emptied ♪
♪ So tell me where
to put my love ♪
♪ Do I wait for time to do what
it does? ♪
♪ I don't know where
to put my looooooove ♪
♪ So tell me where
to put my love ♪
♪ And do I wait for time to do
what it does? ♪
♪ I don't know where
to put my looooooove ♪
♪ My arms emptied ♪
♪ The skies emptied ♪
♪ The billboards emptied ♪
♪ My arms emptied ♪
♪ The skies emptied ♪
♪ The buildings emptied ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]